Bip, bip, bip, bip,
bip, bip, bip.
Bip, bip, bip, bip, bip.
Bye bye, boo!
Okaidina.
Happy.
Gojo, jay, mojo.
Hello, everybody.
Welcome in.
Hi.
Oh, why is the chat dead?
That's so true.
It's already not working very well.
Refresh.
You guys say you're waiting on me, but...
Oh.
You guys are dead to me on the screen.
Are you guys even real?
Are you guys even here?
Hello, hello, hello.
Hi, hi, hi, hi, hi.
That's been weird for a lot of content creators today.
Oh, has it?
Hmm.
YouTube.
Being YouTube.
As usual.
You guys are a figment of my imagination.
Everything is...
Every chatter is me.
But...
With a hundred different accounts.
My voice is sounding better today.
Oh, that's good.
I'm still a little bit of a squeakster.
I'm still a little bit of a squeakster, unfortunately,
but...
Ah, Minto...
Hello, thank you!
Hello, Minto, and I was like you.
Can I wait to do some work with you?
I'm going to be working on...
Making sure my power doesn't go out.
Oh, no!
Stay safe!
Stay safe with the power!
I have quite a long list of things to do.
I have one, two, three, four, five, six things.
Five to six things that I am...
Working to finish tonight.
I had...
I fully anticipated on doing a normal like gaming stream.
And then I was like...
I have too much to do!
No.
Not that number of things.
It's probably gonna be five things.
But I finish.
Not that number that you guys are saying.
I'm a rainbow Ivo now!
Rugby, rabbi, thank you!
Any spoilers on what you're doing?
I'll have to brainstorm some stuff.
I have to go through some of the submissions that the Denchi
did for the super secret Den Setsu project.
aka the song I'm pretty sure it was said that there was a
song coming out a new densetsu song so and some people
submitted for it so I'll be going through those and I have
to do some other stuff I can't say which I think it's some
inspiration for things I have to do my taxes and
I have to do my taxes and I have of important, of important
email to respond to, which will take a little bit of
research to respond to.
Good company while I work through Linux scripts will stop me
from alt F4 in Minecraft.
Spotties, welcome to membership, thank you.
Studying Japanese while watching you.
Oh, yes, please get some work done.
If you have some as well.
Just finished 12 hours at the office, guess I could work
some more.
No!
I will try to chit-chat in between certain things.
I will try to chit-chat, you know, have a big act test
tomorrow.
So please wish me good luck.
Good luck, Bloody Ocean!
Good luck!
I got a study today too.
I don't often do work streams, work along streams.
but I just ended up having so much stuff and I didn't want
to not stream so here we are it's it's a pretty chill stream
I'm still in a hotel so it's a little scuffed fair thee well
where where where am I going what is to work boys Wait,
actually, I do want to test something real quick.
I want to make sure, because some of this stuff is actually
super secret, that I am working on.
So I can't let you hear.
So I'm going to test if you guys can hear.
Can you guys, first of all, can you hear the beautiful BGM
being played at the moment?
Let me know.
Yes, I'm...
Oh.
I just heard a dono come through.
Oh, wait, the notive is...
My notive start turned off.
I'm so sorry.
Yes, you can hear it.
Okay, good, good.
I can't hear it.
MVP by Sanova, yes, yes.
If you enjoy the BGM so much, you should go listen to it on
the Den Setsu EXE channel.
Wait, where'd the dono go?
No!
Wait, hold on.
bed.
Hold on.
My throat today.
Maybe I should.
Maybe I should take a mint.
A voice mint.
I
hear mint yapping.
My favorite.
That is part of what I will be doing today.
Well, some yappen.
Some.
What do you mean, nine minutes to cannibalism?
I didn't mention cannibalism.
Little.
I mean, don't working hard or hardly working.
Phil.
Thank you, Phil.
Oh, my gosh.
Thank you so much.
No, it's over!
Working night ships for my own ship and trying to catch up
on VODs when I can.
Meanwhile, listening to the streams, I can catch on the way
to work.
Let's good luck with work!
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
What the heck?
Night ships seem so rough.
Seems like people...
People...
Uh...
Like, I feel like it would be hard to keep up with friends,
you know?
Speaking of that number... Oh, wait, I just opened up the
donuts.
Speaking of that number, spoiler, maybe thoughts on it
appearing in the NSO anime.
Ducky, I don't get it.
I don't get it.
Night shift is in fact rough.
I believe.
Did you watch the first episode?
No.
I haven't had time.
Working day shifts right now.
Mint is great entertainment as usual.
I was going to wait to watch the show with a watch along for
a needy girl.
I wanted to do a watch along, but...
Perfect stream for packing!
Leaving tomorrow at 3 a.m.
I don't even know they had flights that late.
What the...
Or early?
Wouldn't you consider it to be...
I feel like 3 a.m.
still feels like late night, and then 4 a.m.
is when it becomes the morning, right?
Red eye.
Lights all night, baby.
Is that really?
Either that or 5 a.m.
5 a.m.
is what I consider early.
I feel like because I've...
up for 4 a.m.
flights before you know like I've woken up at 4 a.m.
to get to a flight I feel like 4 a.m.
feels like a morning time that's in my opinion oh oh I was
gonna test the audio let me test let me test let me test let
me know if you can hear I have to put on like a video or
something I'll just put on one of my old streams or i'll put
on uh
i'll put on portal here we go let me know if you can hear
this
can you hear
no okay awesome okay awesome doesn't seem like it i feel
like i'm half falling asleep okay perfect just hear the
piano btm okay Well then, let's see.
I have some stuff here.
Let me bring this down to my other monitor.
Let me keep chat right there.
Let me...
Do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do
do do do do.
Long chat rendering looks funny.
I know, my chat's all broken.
My chat's all broken.
I'm sorry.
I just have to...
Ignore it.
Did I say the hamster dance?
I hummed
it.
It was dangerously close.
What the heck?
Why are there multiple links for this?
Ah, okay, interesting.
Why are there multiple links for some of these?
Why are there so many links for so many years?
DMCA incoming.
Do I sound like the exact...
I sound like the exact hamster?
We haven't been taking care of the May Cafe while Mint was
out.
We let chat break.
No!
The hamster dance is actually the song from Disney's Robin
Hood.
So if you feel like you knew it before, then...
You did.
Wait, chat died.
Oh my gosh, why?
You're right.
Uh-oh.
Maybe you guys are right that it's being funky today.
Refresh.
I think it just broke.
Wait, it's...
Oh, oh.
There we go.
The hamster dance died of cringe.
I said, no hamster dance.
You probably just scrolled it.
No, I didn't.
No.
Because it's a browser thing on OBS.
It's actually impossible for me to scroll it.
It's not even possible.
It's just YouTube being stupid.
She learned to scroll OBS.
I've developed psychic powers.
Got my buddy to play MGS.
Psycho Mantis is going to tear the poor guy apart.
Love the BGM.
I have to keep looking around to figure out which hotel
lobby I'm in.
What do you mean?
That doesn't sound like elevator music, does it?
Maybe a little bit.
Toss asparagus in a mixture of olive oil, salt, pepper,
finely minced garlic, put in 400 degree to oven 15 minutes,
finished with dill and lemon zest.
Actually wait.
It actually sounds awesome.
Do my cat ears wiggle?
Ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, watch them wiggle.
Watch them dance.
Watch them wiggle.
Watch them bounce.
Watch them dance.
Watch them wiggle, wiggle, wiggle, wiggle, wiggle, wiggle.
Watch them wiggle.
Watch them dance.
Watch them wiggle, wiggle, wiggle, wiggle, wiggle, wiggle,
wiggle, wiggle, wiggle, wiggle, wiggle, wiggle, wiggle,
wiggle, wiggle, wiggle, wiggle, wiggle.
You know, I scratched them.
Probably even feel good though.
I would allow it.
I would allow one minute of ear scratching time.
Yeah.
One whole minute.
Sorry, I still sound so raspy.
But I will be working now.
I will have my mic on, so you might hear me.
It's not like a...
It's not like a muted situation.
But I'll work on this until I'm done.
I don't know how long it will take me.
to be honest but uh let me open another notepad for my own
reference okay for now what am i working on i'm working on
some housekeeping it's much to do so much to do lots of
stuff that has like very tight tight deadlines that ended up
happening where it's like oh i need this by the end of the
week but I won't have time to do it by the end of the wait
actually do I it says I don't have access to this file ah
never mind I can't okay never mind I have to take this off
my list of things
oh it's time
the recording is for the five gift and thank you
There should be a folder in the drive.
Hopefully he can link that.
Says Phoebe.
Wait, what if I click this?
Oh yeah, I keep saying I do not have access.
Nah, well, thank you.
Okay, I guess I can't do this then.
That kind of sucks.
Okay.
Phoebe's like, Steiner!
I think maybe he's asleep.
Maybe he's asleep.
Time to haunt YouTube since...
Oh!
The chat died again.
Sorry, I'm not gonna be able to keep refreshing it, you
guys.
So if it dies,
I got too much to do.
To be refreshing it over and over again.
If it dies, it dies.
Oh, came back very slowly.
That just be...
Oh.
Steiner said, sick.
I'm awake.
Never mind.
I will be able to do this, maybe.
Chad keeps doing the same thing to me whenever I switch
windows.
What the heck?
We're just causing problems.
Never.
You guys could never be the problem.
Can you hear me typing?
I'm just curious.
Oh, I should put a thing on the screen too that says, Hard
at work for when I'm working.
And then when I'm yapping.
Oh, you can't?
Oh, no.
I feel like that's part of the appeal.
Sorry.
And if he dies, he dies.
Good movie quote.
And also, it applies here.
Let's see.
Let's do a funny font.
Wingdings.
Oh,
it's so tiny now.
Art and at work.
I'm hard at work.
Am I feeling okay?
I'm good.
I am a little sleepy today.
A bit of a long weekend for me.
But not a bad thing.
I'll sleep some more.
Shooed.
I'm going to choose different fight.
Maybe what about this one?
Yeah, that looks professional.
I'm a hard of work.
I'm just, I'm a busy ghost.
I'm a busy ghost.
I don't know if anyone's working on this So I will move to a
different Order of business
Let's see Use comic sands to annoy people I think comic
sands are so cute though
I'll do this It's a little more fun
Oh wait Hmm.
Comic Sans Undertale.
Choo!
Thank you!
Boo da yo!
Thank you, Shepidore, for the donut.
Sorry that you couldn't hear it probably.
Oh wait.
I drank coffee.
Maybe it's not doing so much.
It's just, it's kind of toasty so I feel like I'm more
wrapped in a blanket.
I
do something a little more fun.
Borrito, borrito.
Borrito, borrito, borrito, borrito.
Oh, Rita.
This is good.
I like the chill vibes today.
Thank you!
Yeah, I guess.
Maybe the last couple's dreams have been a little chaotic.
Today is so chill.
Everyone needs a good proper cuppa.
Okay, you tell me where I can get a good cup of tea in a
hotel room.
Also, I like coffee.
I actually like coffee.
I like the taste of it.
Get these Brits out of here.
Get these.
Actually, I drink tea more often than coffee, though.
But I don't have any tea to have in my hotel room.
These are the background noises.
It's enough to satisfy my brain and not distract me from
writing tabletop RPG stuff.
Oh, good luck with your writing.
Super Chat, thank you so much.
You wish you liked coffee?
Hmm, I don't honestly, I...
Well, yeah, I really like the smell of coffee.
Tea without milk in it.
That's how I always drink my tea, though.
Actually, I drink my coffee with milk.
Usually only milk.
Sometimes I put sugar in it.
A coffee with milk and then my tea black is how I do it.
Carly black darn it.
Maybe
the...
Yippee!
Okay.
Thing I needed was finished.
Or was fixed so I can now work on it.
Yahoo!
I'm so sorry if I missed the super tides!
I'm so sorry!
I...
Uh...
I had other tabs open.
Where come my ace combat skill?
I think you're already a master 9.
What did I miss?
One thing, something gamer cups use code boomer.
Thank you, rinsing, rinsing, rinsing, thank you!
Dibi bucks?
You got the job!
International job even.
Huge!
Congratulations!
Congrats!
Yeah, I gotta be super locked in today, guys.
Like, seriously, no dilly-dallying at all.
It's, like, actually serious for me.
I apologize.
I actually have to walk in.
PSNobon?
No!
It's not that I want to ignore you guys or anything.
Just, uh...
You know.
Like I said, just gotta lock in.
Just gotta lock in.
Do I look sleepy?
I'm looking at my bottom monitor.
So, I am kind of looking down and I'm gonna look at chat and
looking up.
Thank you so much for the Toaani gift Thank you Thank you so
much Thank you Thank you Thank you Thank you Thank you Thank
you Thank you I wish
though My internet is being pretty bad So I might have to
give up on this for a bit Born to be forced to Lockin.
I guess I was born at some point.
Since I am dead.
Died to lockin.
I died to lockin.
Yeah.
Born to be Ippie.
Died to lockin.
Sounds so goofy.
Okay.
I think I finished this one thing.
Me, sure though oh
yeah oh yeah oh yeah that's good that's good that's good oh
holy moly that was so loud tough scallions thank you i
successfully defended my master's thesis i don't know how to
feel right now but i'm glad it's over your streams in front
of me to keep pushing but also making me feel better when i
feel like a dumb dumb that's what i suppose mean is it
because you're watching somebody that is dumber than you huh
i couldn't i've done it without you you are her top
scallions congratulations thank you so much for the super
chat thank you
mint is her
i think i
my part.
She did the thing.
I did the thing.
Oh, rarity.
Okie dokie.
Defending your thesis is like presenting it and handling
questions and critiques.
It seems so stressful to be like, I put in this research and
effort into my thing.
my idea, my hypothesis, and then people to be like,
like how, for anyone that's done it before, it's like a
tower defense.
Well, for anyone that's done it before, like how in depth do
they go in the questions, right?
Like,
Just hit them with your nitpicking and biased, I win, bye
bye.
I think that'd work, probably.
To test of completion, the discipline can be very
scrutinizing.
I got fried during my defense?
I mean, that was hard at work?
So am I.
Good luck with work!
Depends on who's judging your work.
Do you get, like, a...
Then you get like a practice run before you actually go
through the defense.
They tell you like, hey, we're going to test you online.
And then they...
A practice with my coworkers.
practice with others.
When my brother got his PhD, my mom tried to convince me to
go for one and my brother said that PhD isn't worth the
effort.
I've heard that before too, though.
Death Pigeon.
Thank you for the super chat.
I'm surrounded by geniuses.
Usually there are several dry runs.
But not with the people who are actually going to do it.
So like you could do it with your classmates or something
actually What kind of does this thesis class with?
Yes, I'm working hard too because I just got a race like a
gradient congratulations
Thank you so much for that big working hard or hardly
working.
I got one thing done already of my of my to-do list There is
one thing that's going to be like the big, the big baddie,
which will take me a lot of concentration.
But I'll do that last, I think.
Or, yeah, I'll do that last.
That will be my most ultimate concentration, most ultimate
brain cell using total, total no-nonsense work.
Good luck with your work!
I'm working too, let's do our best.
Felicity, good luck, good luck, good luck.
My brain, yes, exactly.
My brain will look like that.
Oh, no, you bombed yours.
Had a research project in my last university because its
requirement had to make a website.
I guess I kind of, I went, I, I did school, some school for,
uh, uh, uh, for film and I had to make like a final thing
like a final film project so I guess if I were going for
like a super film I would have had done a better or a bigger
project maybe I defended my thesis by simply eating the
others I was the largest person there
I don't think you have to eat them.
Ultimate brain cell?
The Acelot brain cell?
Yeah, super film, super film.
I don't have such a big appetite.
I eat a little bit and then I'm hungry like two, three hours
later, you know?
So it worked.
We had a research project and our Clients kept changing what
they wanted for the end goal.
It didn't work out at the end, though.
That's good.
That's one way to defend your thesis.
I think that, honestly, can apply to much in life.
If you're trying a job interview, eat the competition.
Tournament, eat the competition.
Uh...
An event where you want to be, uh, towards the front, or,
like, first, eat the competition.
To me, every mother's experience, it depends on the school
and the specific interviewers.
They could be okay, but sometimes they could be mean and or
offended if the thesis goes against their beliefs.
What?
I feel like it should be a non-biased crowd.
That's kind of crazy.
What do you mean?
It should be totally objective.
For my computer engineering bachelor's, I had to build a
thing with a team.
Open-ended what we could make.
Drones used to be called quadcopters.
then.
Choo, thank you.
Choo, choo, choo.
Slice for thank you.
Work on Minto.
I am.
Thank you so much.
Some professors are crazy.
Okay, that's so fair, though.
Me when I'm in a being tall competition with Minto.
I'm your competition, dude.
You're gonna eat me?
I'm your, wait, I'm your, I'm your competition in a being
tall competition.
It's the ultimately biased crowd sometimes.
Yeah, maybe.
I'm not very tall.
It's not about the actual number.
It's about the height of your heart.
The heart disease.
Pushes up glasses.
Ah, technically drones and quadcopters aren't the same
thing.
A quadcopter is just a flying machine with four rotors.
It has to be autonomous to be a drone.
The height of the heart.
The minnow is very tall.
For good I had this.
Thank you, Reiser!
Once I had to debate my physics professor, that light moves
faster than sound, and so lidar could get cleaner and full
than soda, purely because they just bought a soda for
research use.
I'd love that when you get to prove your professor wrong.
I am in a competition and my opponent is you.
I am very hungry.
Well you know what, Min?
I'm also very hungry.
How?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, how hungry.
I wasn't trying to be dramatic and extend that.
I was trying not to yawn.
Tip, write a thesis on snake venom's effect on people.
How are they going to challenge it?
Venom, snake?
Wait, like venom snakes effect on people?
Wait.
Wait, like, Like...
Like Venom Snake?
Where he says...
Wait.
Minto's heart taller than Fujisan!
Yeah!
As someone that's not in the creative space, I literally
just turn up to work and answer a phone and have no frame of
reference.
What sort of work is involved in the background of being
Minto?
Mmm!
I mean...
I love to...
That's a great question.
I just recently updated my resume.
And I also was wondering that.
I was like, what do I do?
Because I have to think of...
I have to think about what I do Wait, I mean Like what I'm
going to do Like what kind of stream I'm going to do I have
to keep up with The trends Or sometimes I don't I have to
What did I write Wait, hold on Let me just pull up my resume
Okay Let's see.
What did I write?
Let's see.
It's fun here if you don't keep up with the trends.
Sometimes I don't do that too.
Sometimes I have no idea what's going on.
Okay, let's see it.
I wrote I had to grow and manage my YouTube channel.
while following algorithm changes.
Because the algorithm is not kind to anybody.
I have to manage emails and daily Twitter posts.
My daily Twitter posts such as, Good morning, Minto.
I am the creative director of my image branding and
merchandising.
That is true.
I have the final say in things that I, if I'm getting an
artwork done, I'm like, no, you forgot this or this needs to
be changed.
Blah, blah, blah, blah.
That work maxing?
Very difficult work, please understand.
Yes, yes.
Uh, producing in-person events.
I've done that before.
Uh, that's about, I think I don't know what else I do.
You have to manage 400k people.
I did write how many subscribers I have in my resume, but
that's so embarrassing.
I think it's really embarrassing to say, I have this many
followers on Twitter.
I'll also lock in for the night.
Also, would you kindly enjoy the rest of your vacations?
Thank you, Lance!
Thank you.
Thank you so much for the pink.
I will lock in tonight.
And then I will also enjoy the rest of my vacation after I
finish all of my work, baby.
Yeah.
Which I'm about to do.
I'm about to get back to it.
In the business world, it's good to show numbers.
That's what other people told me too.
Highly.
receptive to market trends drives clear you guys should have
helped me with my resume drives clear communication to a
team of over 400k people innovator thought leader event
organizer i am a jack of all trades
numbers and trends too scary too scary at this point just
chat gpt i've never used chat gpt before never tried it what
if I fall psychosis what if it tells me I'm a god and that I
it tells me I'm a god and that my chosen purpose is that I
must like start doing some really obscure like collection of
antique goods and then only then will I realize my potential
because the antique goods used a use like a radio like the
like the like the um uranium pottery or what not uh the
glassware and we're gonna lose her guys it's so funny how i
i see sometimes like tiktoks of of people that like kind of
test the accuracy of chat gpt and it's so funny the guy will
be like hey can you ta the one i watched recently the I was
like, hey, can you time how long I run a mile for?
And ChatGPT was like, yeah, sure thing.
I will start the clock and then tell me when you're done
running the mile and I'll tell you what your time was.
And he goes, okay, start.
And then like literally like two seconds later, he goes, he
goes, okay, finished.
What was my time?
And ChatGPT goes, all right, good job.
Your time was 10 minutes.
and he's just like oh oh really I thought it was more like
five seconds and it was like no sometimes you get a little
overconfident and you could think that you were faster than
you really were but you actually ran for 10 minutes
like it seriously tries to gaslight you it's kind of insane
it's so funny because it's so bad it's so wrong min phantom
uranium keychain glow at night merge yeah i've heard of
those profits that's some actually scary stuff yeah i don't
know wait actual profits you maintained customer facing
social media presence and engagement daily on twitter as an
independent aren't you also responsible for contracts with
third parties procurement and financial records and I don't
know how to do any of that I need a person that does all my
financing I'm stupid with it
It just makes stuff up It really does It really does It's
kind of insane So I don't ever use it I think it might be
good for like Well you know Asterisk but like you know if
it's like uh i need ideas for something um shoot some ideas
for like i don't know anything but maybe like when you're at
a loss for something i know some people that will use it for
like making lists maybe that's a good reason for it but i'm
i'm i'm old-fashioned i think i do everything analog still
in a sense so I'm a boomer, I can't teach this cat new
tricks.
Just use people to shoot ideas and make lists.
There you go.
I consult the encyclopedias.
Based boomer.
They're okay when you give them a piece of information like
a dog.
and then ask them to make questions about said document.
Oh, I've heard of like students that will do that.
They'll feed their notes to the model and then kind of make
like flashcards based off of it.
I can't help with finances, but I can offer snacks.
That's even more important.
Thank you, Folly.
No talk.
But, okay, I go back to work now.
I go back to work now.
Okay, this one might, I don't know how long this one will
take me, so I'll just, I'll just, I'll just chat when I can.
Let's see.
Thank you, Lord!
Sorry, I'm listening to the voice, to the voice submissions.
You guys sound so cute.
Who is this?
I'm not being mean.
It's so cute.
I get to hear you guys.
It might even be...
It might even be somebody in chat.
That was good.
Who was it?
I'm not gonna say...
I will say, I will embarrass.
But it's fun to hear.
You can say if it's me, Minto.
It's not.
You do just want to be humiliated, Kapoor.
So cute.
I think this one's good.
Basically, you have to check and make sure for the mixing
that like the audio quality is good so that we're not just
sending to the artist so many like you know voice voice
recordings and you know then they have to go through them
because they might not be like the best quality to use
I'm kicking my feet oh my gosh you sound so cute okay let's
do the next one that one should be good
Please say thank you.
Say please and thank you.
Honestly, binary ghost, I've been saying please and thank
you to my Google home since I first got it.
I'll be like, hey Google, what's the weather for today?
And I'll tell me I'll be like, okay, thank you.
Or be like, set an alarm for 20 minutes, please.
Thank you.
I feel like it's good to just keep manners like that though.
Isn't it not, you will be spared.
I've thought about that though.
I'm like, what if, oh gosh, it's like that.
It's that bowling animation, spared.
My mommy taught me to say please and thank you to everybody
who is doing me a service or help.
a favor so i i even to even to mr a mr google ai i say
please and thank you
animation not the bowling animation it feels weird not to be
nice i know renew remove those name from the list people
that bully their their it just doesn't feel right it's like
those robot dogs when people bully them you know so funny
let's make another list
oh wait actually let me
you guys have really high quality sounding like mics and
stuff it's good thank you
So cute.
How many submissions?
I think it was 80 something.
But I'm not going through all of them.
We divided them between the three of us.
Who
was this?
Who did this one?
So cute.
Recorded from the closet.
That's the perfect place to be honest, not gonna lie.
Thank you.
Our denti are cute.
Make another list, managing workflow to optimize
productivity and organizational time.
I love lists.
Is anyone else?
I can't.
Yeah, I can't exist without lists.
Me.
Santa Claus.
Yeah, I call me Mrs. Claus.
I love these.
I want to do more.
I love listening to you guys.
Good.
Good, good.
They are the guys, like, cutie-p-duty.
Nice mic quality.
If you do, more people are bound to participate.
So good.
I like seeing people's names that I recognize, and I'm like,
oh my god, it's you!
It's just me or the quality of USB cheap mics improved so
much over the past few years.
No, you're right, I think.
Yeah, I mean...
It's definitely nice so that people don't feel like they
have to go buy a whole interface and everything, you know.
All the stuff that comes with that.
If you get to mine and it sounds bad, give it to me
straight.
So cute.
Yeah, I'm gonna go look for yours.
I found it.
I'm going to listen to it.
It's not part of my batch, though, to listen to, though.
Don't do it.
Oh, it's good.
It sounds good.
Wait, hold on.
I got to put in both ears for this.
Both earbuds.
Let's see.
Yeah, yeah.
The quality is really good.
Thank you.
I'm concerned about the sound quality of my submission.
That's totally okay.
Oh, this one's good.
Sounds like Ash Ketchum.
Oh, it sounds so good.
Thank you.
Fusion Harbor.
ship thank you why is matara watching clips of me right now
she's talking about dinner with your manager oh
she's defending herself look i was not there i can only say
i can only give you guys i could only tell you guys the
information That was given to me.
So...
That?
Everything that I told you guys is all that I know.
I also want to say that as I'm going through these voice
clips...
For those who don't know, there was a Den Zetsu fan chant...
Submission that we did last month.
through them now to double check like audio quality and
everything to then send to the uh to the mixers and stuff
but i know that also for some people especially you know if
you don't record things usually if you don't uh if you don't
um you know if you don't do anything like this it could
like nerve-wracking so thank you guys if we went out of your
if you went out of your comfort zone you know jersey thank
you so much for the day i get it thank you thank you thank
you thank you i was cringing so hard at my own voice that's
how i feel all the time so
so i get it i get like you know you're probably just like i
didn't want to record my voice is so cringe or something but
no so good
but it's also just fun to do like things that you guys can
interact with too
there's so many though holy cow
you didn't know what to send oh Phoebe made a guide for it
it was like part of the submission form but we'll do more in
the future don't worry if you missed out this time
Look out in the future.
Um,
actually there were six parts.
Good, good, good, good.
Let's see.
Next.
Honestly, these all sound way better than...
i i expected maybe like people recording like discord audio
quality phone you know but no these sound good
i yeah honestly i'm just like i i think we could use like
all of these so good yippee
Some of the chants make me like they make me laugh because
not the way like the way you guys say it but it's like it's
a funny thing to say so it makes me laugh.
I had to go buy a mic.
You did that for just for this.
Wait.
Dedication.
I know.
Oh, it's so awesome.
Thank you guys.
Wait, which one am I?
This one?
Yeah.
Reason through these, honestly.
Which is great.
We have like 10-ish left.
Is Hideo Kojima my special guest?
I can't give you anything.
I can't.
I just can't give you any hints.
I mean...
She didn't say no.
I honestly, I don't know at all when it's going to be
announced.
It's not for dramatic.
effect I'll tell you that for sure that the reason it hasn't
been announced is not like oh it's something really crazy
and therefore it's being announced it's taking a long time
for it to be announced I think it's just a matter of how do
you say um probably you know Steiner's been busy and it
could be that the person's team is also busy so getting like
a finalized like you know
hello hello hello are we back
phobias crashed my bud i don't know i don't know what
happened she was right about to leak it
too close to telling us they pulled the plug i wasn't but
now i won't say anything i don't know actually what was the
last thing i said so uh well too bad too bad yeah they had
to silence me
thank you bro and i love you
Thank you for the pink.
Don't send me super chats.
Makes me feel bad.
She leaked who it was, but the stream was down.
I said it a million times.
And if you didn't hear it, if it didn't get projected into
your soul, how from me saying it, then you're just never
gonna...
You're never gonna know.
Some of you guys submit.
committed so many.
Holy cow.
Mr. Yum Yum.
Thank you!
Do you just say you're not my mom?
You're not the boss of me?
I am your mom.
I'm the boss.
She told me telepathic.
Oh my god, that was scared me.
I don't know if you saw me jump.
Sorry, I feel better for the call.
but I read it was important to say, Hydrate when sick.
Can you spare some fluids?
Right?
Oh, I do have a sports drink right next to me.
Would you like some?
It's a peach flavor.
I'm setting an August open.
It's a 4-me total.
We gotta check coming in two days.
Bloody Ocean!
What the heck?
Thank you!
Great.
Now I'm Thursday.
Well, get yourself a sports drink.
I don't know what to tell ya.
I didn't think my friend was serious about going to see you
for me as a meet and greet.
Oh, yeah, Detective Koo!
I was shocked when she sent the video.
Soon she'll be an eyeball too.
Oh, your friend was so nice!
Thanks for... Thank you to her for coming to see me.
I'm losing at my game.
Please help.
What do you want me to do?
How am I supposed to help, huh?
How am I supposed to help?
No Elp.
I don't even know what game it is.
What if it's Fortnite?
I'd get you number one victory royale every time.
Do you think there are...
Like, uh...
What's the word?
Do you think there are Valentine's cards that are just like,
I would, I would, I would, I would, yeah.
If I, I would bring you to Victory Royale.
Can love really bloom in the afterlife?
I don't think so.
Maybe.
I've seen, I've read it in Dojin Shi.
Yes.
Do you think there's, do you think it stutters just like
that?
Do you, do you think it would be like, I would, I, for you,
for you, I would, to get, I, I would get number one victory,
together, I would get number one victory for, Royale, for
you, I don't know why I struggle with this, so, it might
seem like a bit, but it's not.
It's because I'm struggling with how to say it.
Dolgen, tomes of truth.
Art imitates life.
All right.
I dedicate this play of the game to you.
Oh, that's good.
That's good.
Your voice is too calming for work.
No!
Again!
And I guess Minto and I would love for my fluffy girl kit.
She's going to have a nasty skin tag.
Oh, she's going into her nasty skin tag and possibly a tooth
removed tomorrow.
Most horrific if she has to miss two of me.
No!
Okay, Bo.
Oh, your little precious girl.
No.
Oh, to a meal.
That's a lot.
That's a lot for...
Is it a cat?
For an animal.
Kee.
Oh my god.
Freaky light!
I'm in tomorrow.
I'm being forcefully volunteered.
Sent to the Arctic for work.
They have no internet there, so I'll be missing your streams
for...
for a while.
That sounds so awesome for Elijah!
Thank you, first of all, thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you so much for the Hakusupa.
But also, that sounds so awesome!
It's the Arctic, not Antarctic.
Arctic, be careful of a polar bear.
Make sure you have your protection from the polar bears that
are hungry.
Good luck!
Have fun!
Wait, I want to hear all about it when you're back.
That's so awesome.
Someone did the calls?
Someone did the calls is like a death metal voice.
I'm keeping it.
It's great.
It's perfect, actually.
So it's like...
Not much!
First time donate, keep it up!
Kaolaou!
Thank you!
What do you mean it's not much?
Oh my gosh, any tiny...
Any amount is a big amount.
And even if you think it's a tiny amount, any amount is so
much appreciated.
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
Yes, yes, yes.
Alright, I'm on the last one!
But I do have to go over a couple other ones.
Let's see.
Almost two years since I got the phantom virus.
Ghost of rain.
Almost two years.
Also mentally, welcome back.
Thank you.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Okay.
Let's do that.
I have to go back through.
this time flies it does right it does it's already april
it's not thank you thank you thank you
let's see
okay almost done
After four hours of being hard at work, you need to consult
a doctor.
The doctor is...
Dr. Shoals.
Because you gotta get up and walk out of your chair.
Almost boss fight?
Yeah.
I love the way some of the reflections and these are.
Walking it off can be a legit thing.
it.
Yeah, baby.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, wait.
Oh, wait.
I have one more to do.
Just kidding.
I'm a liar.
Oh, my God.
It's somebody in chat.
Let's see.
Oh!
Whoa!
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
It's good, it's good, it's good.
Popped in real quick while I work.
Good luck with work!
Good luck
with work!
Hmm.
Okay.
How many total names I recognize?
Many.
Many of them, actually.
I crafted my endgame item.
Lucky stream.
Let's go!
Alright.
I just handled that.
So I can take that up the list.
Ta-da-da.
Alright.
Let's do some email.
Stuff that I gotta do.
Anyway, I don't talk much here.
I'm always reading where I mean, though thank you thank you
thank you i appreciate it so much of course lurkers are
always loved and welcomed as well i'm gonna ask it's awesome
how you can recognize so many fans really well i think you
know if you if you don't then it's i mean these are the
people that are supporting being able to help me do what I
want to do, so...
It's even more important to be able to do so.
I'm lurking here!
I was mentioned!
I do my best, at the very least.
Hello?
Male?
Do you want to load?
Hot dog!
I just got a hot dog.
Boss fight means to punch your boss in the head.
Work sucks.
No job, nut job, not tired.
Magic donuts!
Dough.
You're hired, you're hired, you're hired.
Ugh.
My brain.
We should really finish this 40-hour Minto Clip compilation.
40-40 hour Minto Clip compilation.
Of what?
What could be 40 hours?
Me and Minto live stream go brrrrr.
CARD!
Yay!
Why East?
Cause...
Wait.
The rest cut off.
Cause I get the bread.
Hello, boss.
Hello, Chad.
It's been a minute.
Hope everyone has been well.
Yes.
Checking in to make sure your health is in tip-top shape.
And to drop off Minto healthcare installment.
Yes.
I finished my medicine today.
Been quite busy, but it's been a great problem to have.
May you see many blessings and prosperity.
Thank you!
Brenny Con- Kanye!
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you so much for the Aqua Soup.
Give me one second, you guys.
I have to go get my phone.
It's been on the charger.
I gotta get my phone for this, so.
Give me one second.
Let's see.
Let's see, let's see, let's see
Dargo, thanks
She's so fast It was right across the... it was right behind
me Alright Let's see, I have to Answer some questions for
this email And then I will be done with that So let's see
It could be a really big room guessing you're finally
recovering from the sickness oh yeah i feel great i feel i
feel like you know i have a bit of a cough still but i think
that's just you know um just little little tiny residue
residual whatever whateverness and i took my last medicine
today and my voice only is a little squeaky because i used
it a lot so So, um, yeah.
No longer down with the sickness.
Wow.
No.
Hot dog indeed.
I forgot you guys can't hear the hot dogs.
The Jesus.
Hello, Mint.
I would like to let you know I refuse your job offer.
I don't...
Wait.
I'm offering you a job?
Or you offered me a job and then refused me?
Wait, which is it?
Wait.
I'm not going back to heaven, am I?
No!
Oh, shoot.
Okay, oh gosh.
Okay, wait.
Actually, I need something.
I need my passport.
I thought...
Wait, wait a second.
I do need my phone.
Just kidding.
I'm a liar.
Um...
Uh...
Don't you dare, don't do it!
What am I doing?
I need my passport to get into heaven.
You know what's really cool is in my passport I have...
Oh, don't you dare go back to heaven?
Oh, goodness gracious, no.
I think I'm okay.
Um...
One thing I have that's cool in my passport is... is a a um
a visa to antarctica from port lock roy heaven's overrated
yeah exactly exactly exactly all right
no this doesn't have everything oh shoot uh
holy cow okay Oh,
it doesn't say though...
Oh, this is frustrating.
Uh, let's see.
I do not know.
Meet and greet in Antarctica incoming.
What am I doing right now?
I'm getting some information for an email that I must
respond to.
Nothing says...
Wait.
Okay, wait.
Oh, I'm a genius.
Gosh, you guys, I'm a genius.
I don't understand.
Just, you don't, I can't tell you what I'm doing, but, uh,
just know I'm a freaking genius, okay?
Just know I'm a genius.
Ah!
We are aware.
All right.
Very good.
This
is so much like Just data, right?
Oh Did it come back?
Are we back?
I don't know what happened OBS crashed and then One of my
monitors also Turned off.
I'm thinking Maybe the Uh Maybe like the power supply is not
great because I'm in a...
My hotel room is one of those like...
It doesn't have outlets.
I had to plug into a lamp that had an outlet.
You know what I mean?
So maybe it's not great.
If?
Uh...
If it goes out again, though, I think I will just call it
there.
I know that actually I'm going to be losing my camera soon.
Because for some reason, it doesn't want to charge anymore.
Twas a mini counting indeed.
Good job, team.
Yeah, you guys got to 21.
Good job.
But for now, we persevere.
we persevere i might actually just finish up this thing and
then maybe call it i don't know it's so short though did you
keep your progress i lost some stuff i did unfortunately but
some stuff i uh was able to save which is good evening boss
i'm late but i am working hope you don't work too hard you
too told the p thank you counted good for you, Boisu.
I know, very good, very high number.
I'm proud of you all.
Let's see.
Actually, you know what?
I'm not going to use Notepad because I'm afraid of losing
everything again.
So, that's A-OK.
You'll make back the progress in no time.
Yeah, I think so too.
I was able to save it somewhere and I don't know where
actually.
Hot dog, thank you.
Wait, where did I save this?
Wait, oh, oh, I saved it.
Okay, I saved it.
I remember.
Driver says thank you.
Big energy, babe.
For me, though, I was the crystal work.
You caught this.
Thank you.
Hello, my hardworking wife as well.
Hello, Dasko.
I love you.
Remind me.
stream to send you my outfit so you can make art if you want
for off cut remind me remind me
okay oh shoot I gotta go
is there a way to fix the funny long text message pinto or
you just leave it like that I think if there was a way for
me to fix it I would have by now but
YouTube YouTube changed their CSS changed something that
messed up my chat CSS and I actually don't know how to fix
it so it's not me
that's a job for someone else to figure out CSS issues are
hard yeah I don't know what happened truly
it's so frustrating because I love my chat I love the way it
looks so much.
And now it's like, I'll mess up.
Wee.
YouTube is just so cool, right, Minto?
Oh, yeah.
Also, look what else they changed.
So basically, I have to crop it every time, but they changed
this too.
Where is my chat?
Let's see.
All right, guys.
There you guys are.
See, look at this.
It never used to say that.
the sign-in to chat.
Nope, that's a brand new edition that YouTube just thought
needed to be there.
So...
Uh...
Sign-in!
It's cool, though, seeing the long messages get chopped up.
I'm glad you like it.
I'm just kind of giving up.
I've given up on it.
Alright, back to my data that I was collecting before.
Back to my data, back to my data.
Da-da-da-da-da-da.
This is also a 20.
This is the wrong year.
Okay.
She's collecting my data.
Don't cut me in half of YouTube.
Oh, YouTube, please.
I would hate to be cut up in half of YouTube.
Please.
Please don't do it, please.
Welcome back, Minkees.
Thank you.
Sorry for having tech issues, guys.
I'm sorry.
Would you rather be cut in half horizontally or vertically?
I think horizontally.
I think vertically has a lower survival rate than being cut
in half horizontally.
horizontally.
I think both would hurt.
Yeah.
But I think, okay, say, say I get cut in half horizontally.
No, say I get cut in half vertically.
If I am a zombie, it is, there's no way I would be like you
know zombie and around anymore if i were cut in half
horizontally i would be one of those annoying zombies that
like crawls at you you know what i mean and like would still
be able to bite and be a little nuisance yeah i'd be a
crawler i'd be grabbing ankles left and right
if we're doing vertical vertical do we start from the head
Yeah?
I think so.
Yeah, I'm going for the free.
I'm being a little ankle-biter.
I will, I will.
I will.
Let's see.
Okay, oh.
Oh, this was accurate.
Oh my gosh, my system is accurate.
No, heck can't wait.
Alright.
Oh,
this is kind of annoying.
I'm doing data again.
How much change from here then, Minto?
I'm short too.
Data, data, data, data.
Data, data.
Data, data, data.
Hmm.
Oh yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You guys can still hear the music again, right?
Just making sure on that too.
Not sure.
Fun stars!
You can?
Okay, great.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
What is this?
What the heck?
How did I get that one so wrong?
Jeez.
Okay, I'm gonna have to confirm all of this.
All right.
This requires my utmost attention, guys.
Thank you, Morphe.
Oh my god.
Okay, good.
That was...
Okay, Dan.
Thank you for the pick!
I've been so busy, but I need to do the same for me too.
Thanks for always making time for Ivo.
Everyone thinks they're busy.
No!
Also, no, please, feel...
You can always just come back when you're ever available,
you know, don't want even don't even sweat it oh it was what
changed i was right i was right i was right that
was wrong
what what what
how how i wonder if i could do this actually maybe this
would be easier i don't come Fears.
My, my, my data's all wrong.
What the heck?
Not the data.
Ah.
Okay, never mind, this is useless.
You are useless to me, you are useless to me.
What?
I'm so confused.
Sorry.
I can't explain to you guys what I'm confused about, but I
am very confused.
What?
Okay.
How is that possible?
How is this... No, that's wrong.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, whatever.
I'm just a They're gonna ignore.
What
do you mean you're used to hearing that?
You're used to hearing what?
That I'm confused.
Playing Terraria for the first time every time.
Playing Solo just made the hard mode.
Woo!
Go down the hill!
Thanks for those!
Donkey, okie dokie.
We'll check everything again.
All right.
Okay.
I'm sending, I'm making sense.
BAM!
Thank you!
I think I made sense of it.
Somehow.
Somehow I made sense of it.
We're okay.
All right.
Very good.
Yes.
Ha.
I didn't make sense of it.
Oh!
What a mess this is.
What a mess.
I'm gonna pull my hair out.
This is craziness.
Oh.
Wait, what?
Huh?
What?
I was...
I'm so confused.
I'm
so confused.
And then this one.
Yes.
One.
That's that.
This.
Okay.
I think I figured it most out.
My brain hurts from that.
great job thank you thank you i i didn't finish completely
but i think i got the bulk of it done
i think maybe
hmm people said the accounting ibu's over it's not even my
taxes you guys i haven't even gotten that though i send to
somebody else i say i don't know and i send it off i say and
i send it away
okay i have no idea i'm i can't do this anymore okay i can't
i can't look at anymore the numbers what do they mean i
don't know anymore i give up i give up i give up i give up i
give up i give up i give up i give up i give up i give up i
give up the numbers i don't know
basically i'm having to reference one two
four different things and each thing is giving me a
different number well not always but sometimes sometimes I'm
getting different numbers and I'm like oh how many do you go
to go to come by the money
yeah I hate it when that happens I know that's why I'm like
This doesn't make any sense.
But, yeah.
Alright, let's see what this says.
Okay.
I'm fed of you.
Thank you so much.
What the heck.
Thank you for that.
That's so much.
Close enough.
It's Beryl Clock.
Take a breather.
No.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you.
Give
me a second again.
Oh no!
Guys, my camera is at 10% battery.
Working hard or hardly working.
I think I'm working hard.
Okay!
Wait, why isn't my camera working?
Oh, there it is.
Teacher, let's up if you suddenly freeze up, we won't call
an ambience.
I'm okay.
Maybe.
I'm not okay in the head.
I'm okay.
A little bit.
I thought we were collectively just looking at Locked and
Minto with nice BGM.
Pretty much.
You are more than okay in spirit.
Yeah.
I'll finish this part.
up after stream though so I since I have to quadruple check
everything gonna rest for a while plan to cook my youngest
sisters on baked mac and cheese because it's her birthday
happy birthday to your little sister I want to be can I be
your little sister I want some baked mac and cheese I want
to like possess her on her birthday though I don't want to
possess her oh wait I also need my list of things
We're good, we're good, we're good, we're good, we're good,
we're good, we're good.
What else do I need to do?
Oh my god, you guys!
I'm in California right now.
And last night, I looked out my window.
And I saw this crazy thing flying through the sky.
And I was like, what the heck?
What the heck?
It was like, it like, was like...
It was...
There was a smoke trail, and then it was...
It looked like it was going like supersonic.
Like, there was like a cloud surrounding a thing that was
going really fast.
And I was like, what is that?
And so I went to R slash R... Reddit...
Reddit...
What is this?
And it turns out there was a rocket launch.
And I saw it.
I saw the launch.
It was really cool.
I'll post some pictures later.
Once I'm checked out of this hotel.
But I was like, whoa.
Let's go.
Good job, Reddit.
Yeah, I was like, if anybody knows what this is, it would
be.
It would be Reddit.
Reddit.
It was so cool!
Yeah.
I don't think it was Artemis, though.
I don't know.
I think some people were saying that it was SpaceX.
Unfortunately, you gotta Google Reddit for effective search
analysis.
I know.
I was like, oh my gosh.
This is crazy.
Artemis was a while ago.
Also, Artemis was out of Florida, though.
There's no way.
Isn't that crazy?
Artemis is at Nimi's home.
Oh, you're so right.
My bad.
Yeah.
But I was like, I've never seen anything like that before.
It was so...
I was like...
I could...
I was like, I don't know what this could be.
A UFO?
I was like, am I witnessing alien history?
why is the mint subreddit banned i don't know that was fan
made not run by me why was it banned you ask them don't ask
me insert any question reddit so true
lack of moderators do people really use reddit for vtubers
though i guess i use i guess i'll sometimes go to reddit i
don't have an account or i did i had my old account that but
I don't have account that I use I just sometimes go and I
read MIT asshole when I can't sleep the hololive subreddit
is very active oh depends on the vtuber I don't think I need
a whole reddit to myself though like I think a hololive
subreddit that makes sense but for me just little old me I
don't think I think you need a whole Reddit for just me.
I think, yeah, I don't have that much going on.
There's a post from when you first started VTubing.
Yeah, I made like a little like introduction.
Speaking of Artemis, did you see the pick of Artemis Plushie
and Mission Control?
I did!
So cute!
Oh wait, I thought they had Luna.
Was it Luna or Artemis?
R slash Densetsu EXE.
Maybe a Densetsu.
One could work.
Oh, it's Artemis.
I couldn't remember.
Well, I couldn't remember if it was Artemis.
And like.
Or if it was Luna.
Because it was just like.
Oh, she's waiting for Artemis to come back.
You know what I mean?
I couldn't remember.
Mm-hmm.
Most of VTuber fan subreddits just share a fan or...
Yeah, it's kind of cute, right?
That's why I thought it was Luna.
I couldn't remember.
That would have been clever too.
Yeah, it would have been cute.
Star-crossed lovers, for real.
Whee!
But yeah...
Okay, let's see what's my list of things to do.
Let's see what else I can do.
get done.
I just looked...
Wait, okay, there we go.
My list.
Okay, I took care of that for the most part.
Camera battery, okay?
It's at 6%.
I'll only be able to move for 6% more.
The dinosaur thumbnail of you is adorable.
Isn't it so cute?
again sorry I'll fix it since I'm in between stuff don't
forget us when you pass on
double dead double dead don't wait it wasn't a way it was a
meh not
the emoji.
It was a bleh.
Bleh.
That was a bleh.
Weh for, but it would cause you wouldn't you wouldn't
download a weh for.
What if I make weh for something really cursed?
Like.
Do it.
It would be great.
Glad I lived long enough to save Wehr 4.
But what about me?
I haven't lived at all.
They wouldn't download them, ain't
they?
It's Uemotouch 4.
It's Uemotouch, I feel the kind joy.
Wehr 0.
Return to Wehr.
Mmm.
Nixie, I'm banning you.
I'm banning you.
Ban, ban, ban, ban, ban, ban, ban, ban, ban.
Nixie is banned.
You are banned.
Worth it.
You have been banned.
Bad, you won't be bad.
They did nothing wrong.
How could you say that?
We'll become the number one Minto fan just through the
process of elimination.
Everybody starts getting banned.
Alright, guys.
I gotta get back to work.
What am I doing next?
Maybe I should do my taxes.
Okay.
No.
You only got one week left.
I know.
I don't have time to do it before then, so I gotta send
everything.
Today.
Wait, what the heck?
It like started typing something for me.
That's so weird.
I thought thank you!
Wait, I didn't get to read it.
One moment, please.
I must go read.
I have an offshore bank account on Shadow Moses Island.
That's Alaska.
It's still part of the country.
I don't think it works.
It's off the coast of Alaska.
Oh, no, you're in trouble.
everything!
Erase it all!
Jordan, thank you!
I would offer to take care of joint filing for the rest of
my days.
Delete it!
That's terrible.
Terrifying.
Just send Think to your tax preparer.
They'll understand.
So true.
Though guys, I think I might call it here because I am.
I think I do need to truly focus on some of these.
So.
Let's see.
I have just a couple things left.
Dang, the one thing, the biggest thing I wanted to get to, I
didn't get to today.
But it's not time.
Well, it is time sensitive, but not time sensitive and that
I need to do it today, maybe.
Yeah, you guys are so distracting.
I just want to talk.
But I'll be back Tuesday.
I'll be gone a couple days.
Wait, so that's what?
One week from today?
Yes.
I'm actually gonna go do my vacation.
I'm actually gonna go have a vacation a little bit, so.
Um...
In one week, I'll have a week vacation.
So...
Call of O, thank you!
I played Resident Evil, I got too scared, and I'm watching
you most of the time.
Resident Evil 7, the beginning is so scary.
Thank you for sharing a bit of your work with us today,
boss.
I'm sorry that it couldn't be more of an interesting stream.
I did get some stuff done, though.
You guys were a super huge help.
Thank you for letting me take the time to do some work, too.
Otherwise, I don't think I would have been able to get as
much done as I did, so.
Bring your eyeballs to work, Dave.
It was fun.
Glad we were able to get through a lot.
Wish we could help with the confusing stuff.
Yeah, that's another thing I need to look over and not be
like, I need to really just kind of like sit and lock in for
it so it was interesting I'm glad I cast easy taxes be but
thank you I also do need to rest my voice too so when you
hear me next hopefully I'm not a squeaky squeak squeaksters
hopefully I'm not a squeaksters hopefully I am totally good.
I played Blue Archive the entire stream.
That's crazy.
Maid Mint Vantab, you will be back on the 16th.
If not, somebody in chat has a special day coming up IDKU.
Wait, will you be back on the 16th?
Yes, I will be streaming on the 16th.
Just in case somebody in the chat has a special day, I don't
know who though.
Cover your mystery.
Thank you!
Hope you have a good vacation.
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Who could it be?
Happy belated return anniversary.
Oh my gosh, you're right!
I realized that I was gone for my return anniversary.
But that's okay.
I would much rather celebrate my...
Because you know, it was my return anniversary but also my
graduation anniversary.
Thank you so much for the Dodo.
Thank you!
I would much rather celebrate my anniversary of activities.
So, thanks for the stream.
Faithless Lunar, thank you!
David, thank you!
Report while you were gone.
I got scuba license!
Oh my god!
I did not beer o'clock.
Thank goodness.
Being under 30 feet of water made me appreciate life.
I want to see an eel!
I want to see Thank you guys!
Have a good day, have a good night, have a good time zone
and I'll see you when I see you next which would be Tuesday
for stream.
But I'll be treating still too.
Bye bye!
Thank you so much everybody and thank you, thank you, thank
you!
Bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, sorry again for not
interesting stream and also tech issues and everything, but
it was a lot of fun still.
Bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, have a good rest of your day.
You too!
You too, you too, bloody ocean, thank you so much.
Bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye.